the jurgen experience i went to the
bitcoin conference in miami this year
and just got to see and hear
some really really cool things and the
people who are like pioneering this and
and really believing in in bitcoin
specifically not just like the whole
world of cryptocurrency but bitcoin
itself um i haven't been excited about
something like this in a really long
time and i'm not a finance guy you know
like i'm not a guy who grew up knowing
about you know financial systems and
networks and stock markets or anything
and now i'm finally at a point where i'm
starting to be able to like see a future
for myself and also a way to like
people like me don't really
have
like generational wealth right and i
don't understand i don't see how you
know i can really create that through
fighting alone so lately i've just been
trying to understand more of like
the the advancement of technology and
kind of where we're headed right like
for instance you know when i was a kid
in the 1990s and and
early 2000s when the internet came
versus now
like in that jump in my lifetime it's
night and day difference like i'm living
in sci-fi compared to
what was in the 90s you know
so now just you know listening to people
um
really like
really smart people even like uh yeonmi
park who you had here yeah and hearing
her and how
um she spoke about how like
bitcoin is actually helping save
uh some children from like so
in north korea this is what she said in
north korea when women are are are taken
as sex lives and shipped over to
northern china where these guys are
buying them because china has this
um
this one child rule in in certain areas
right so
if the woman if the if the sex slave has
a child
then that child is half north korean and
half chinese the chinese won't accept
them and they can't go back to north
korea because
the women kind of like escaped right
so
because of that there's actually what
she said are
pretty much millions of stateless
children who can't get birth
certificates who can't get schooling who
can't get anything and they're either
like sent to prison camps as children or
killed
because they're what are they gonna do
with them china doesn't accept them and
they can't go back to north korea so
what happens right so there's like
underground church groups that are
actually taking these kids in
and because they can't use chinese money
and they you know
because it's happening in china because
they can't use chinese money the only
currency that they can use right now is
bitcoin and so people are able to fund
them too so that they can at least
school these kids and
feed them and things like that so from
like a from like a
currency and like money standpoint
there's like a small fraction where i'm
like okay i see how this works but then
trying to uncover and like dive more
into the whole
system
of how this can be implemented into just
like daily society i'm seeing more and
more possibility and it's making me more
and more secure on hey man i can
actually finally have something that i
own
that's mine like whatever i earn
is going to be mine and you can't touch
it
no one can touch it every from
and there's a guy uh adam curry who
thank good buddy yeah yeah you know like
uh
uh podcast index like his now they've
created this thing where
um if you want to have your own platform
and not worry about being taken down or
censored or whatever and you can also
get paid in satoshis which are fractions
of a bitcoin
from the supporters so you can stream
your sats you don't have to buy bitcoin
you can create a platform where hey i'm
speaking if i wanted to start one and
i'm like you know i don't have the money
to actually buy bitcoin but i do have a
lot of stuff that i want to talk about
subscribe to my podcast and then my fans
and my followers are streaming to me
satoshi's just like they would on
instagram like likes right you get them
saying so likes and replays and all that
stuff is also a currency like people
don't really look at it that way but
like yeah a lot of these a lot of these
like companies that want to do business
with me it's like oh how many followers
do you have what's your twitter
engagement what's your instagram
engagement oh this video only got 70 000
plays that's a form of currency because
that's like looked at as
you know my value and my worth on
whether or not you're going to work with
me or not well that's why shadow banning
is so sneaky yeah man it's shadow
banning is so insidious because you're
you're limiting a person's ability to
grow exactly and they do that all the
time with people exactly i think of
bitcoin the same way i think about the
early internet i think they they didn't
see it coming and now it's a viable form
of currency you can actually buy things
with it and i think the government is
freaking out i think what they're going
to try to do is they tried to
they tried to do some [ __ ] with the
internet during the obama administration
where they were gonna try to censor the
internet and it fell apart because
people were furious in the uproar and
they thought the political repercussions
of it were not worth it like the the
juice wasn't worth the squeeze so they
backed off of it but i feel that
there's going to come a time where some
government whether it's the united
states or another government might try
it first they're going to try to
implement i know they already do it in
china but they're trying to going to try
to implement a digital currency a
centralized digital currency that they
can control yeah what's scary about that
is they could say khalil you know we
we've looked at you know your behavior
online and uh you have some
some marks against you yeah and so
you're not going to be able to buy this
yeah or you can only buy staples you
can't you know you can buy food and and
shelter but we're not going to allow you
to travel yeah because like that could
be a real thing where they could
literally limit what you spend your
money on one thousand percent